ça faisait un moment que
les routes étaient des endroits un peu vides
où on se réunissait quand on était
tranquille
[Musique]
on a traversé une année qui nous a mis à l'épreuve
mais on commence à voir la promesse d'
un nouveau jour
depuis plus de cent ans  il y a
un endroit
où nous nous sommes tous réunis pour nous
divertir
pour nous échapper pour aller dans un endroit nouveau
les films
il n'y a rien comme ce moment où
les lumières s'éteignent
les nuits de projecteur
et nous pensons
me dire que vous ne pensez pas à ce que je pense
que vous pensez qu'il y a  pas de pont
oh merde non
bien c'était nouveau
après être restés séparés pendant si longtemps
l'ancienne vie te manque est-ce que tu es tous les jours
il est temps de revenir ensemble
je suis prêt si tu es
mon cul est en feu
nous sommes prêts à te faire croire  encore une fois
whoa
parce que personne ne fait un retour comme les
films
[Musique]
c'est bon d'être de retour
nous vous verrons bientôt
[Musique]
vous